50 toneladas de productos básicos y
artículos de Socorro para Siria esta
ayuda humanitaria donada por Italia
llegó al puerto libanes de beirut para
ser entregada en el marco del mecanismo
de Protección Civil de la Unión Europea
puedes ver important wanderland lo que
es muy importante subrayar es que
estamos haciendo estos simbolitización
queremos llegar a todo el mundo a toda
la población que se ha visto afectada
por esa catástrofe por lo que este envío
irá a todas las áreas es decir en la
parte de la zona controlada por Damasco
y también en el Noroeste donde también
la población Allí se ha visto afectada
muy duramente
11 días después del terremoto la
situación en el noroeste de Siria en
manos de los Rebeldes sigue siendo
especialmente difícil debido a la
lentitud con la que llega la ayuda a la
región devastada y aislada por años de
guerra civil en esta clínica de Live el
de desastre natural afectó a los
suministros médicos y al número de
disponible poniendo aún más al límite el
sistema sanitario
no podemos de la forma más idónea
responder a los heridos a las víctimas
del terremoto necesitamos apoyo
logístico y necesitamos material médico
fungible especialmente para los
pacientes que necesitan tratamiento
continuo cambios frecuentes de vendajes
y fisioterapia y tratamiento de
rehabilitación para que puedan volver a
su vida normal
Hace unos días el gobierno de la sala
autorizó la reapertura de Dos cruces
fronterizos con Turquía hasta el viernes
143 camiones de ayuda de la ONU llegaron
al noroeste de Siria según la
organización un material más que
necesitado para una nación que lleva
casi 12 años sufriendo un conflicto en
el que han muerto cerca de medio millón
de personas